hey guys welcome to the heavy spoilers
show I'm your host definition and this
is the channel where we explain it so
you don't have to this episode will be
covering the premiere of Jordan peels
Twilight Zone reboot titled the comedian
the episode has a lot to unpack from it
and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about it from here on out its
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen the episode yet then I highly
recommend that you turn off now with
that out the way thanks for clicking the
video I hope you enjoyed the show and
let's get into everything you need to
know about the first episode of The
Twilight Zone reboot the episode follows
Sameer wasan who after five years as a
stand-up comedian is struggling to find
success every time it seems like he's
getting somewhere in a gig
the comedian drops a political joke
about the Second Amendment which like
these videos bombs every time one night
after a very rough show Sameer meets JC
wheeler a comedian that Sameer has been
a longtime fan of and JC tells him to
drop all the political stuff and to
actually start talking about himself
rather than things around him the next
night Sameer puts this into action and
tells a story about his dog named cat
which causes the audience to burst out
laughing oh I don't really know why all
seems to be going well
however when Sameer returns home he
can't find his dog anywhere and things
get weirder when his girlfriend tells
him that they never had one the next
night Sameer does another show and after
his political material bombs once more
he turns to his ten year old nephew
Devin and begins roasting him whilst the
crowd loved it
Devin disappears and upon asking his
girlfriend she tells him that they don't
have a nephew and that his sister can't
even have kids
yikes clearly something is going on and
Sameer quickly realizes that the
subjects of his jokes are slowly
disappearing whenever he mentions there
initially this seems like a bad thing
however on the flip side Sameer realizes
that he can make whoever dislikes this
video disappear from existence
Sameer wipes out a whole group of people
and this sends him on a path to success
unfortunately though Sameer slowly
starts running out of people to talk to
and there
or jokes the entire thing backfires when
Samir begins joking about his
girlfriend's mentor from Law School who
thinks is a total creep whilst the
comedy club initially loved the material
Samir realizes that in removing David
from existence
his girlfriend's entire life has been
altered and she ends up working as a
waitress because of it
JC pays Samir another visit and it seems
like Samir is pretty desperate to
reverse all of its changes but JC
reminds him just how close he is to
achieving his dreams
Samir reluctantly gets on stage but has
a mental breakdown and begins listing
tons of names in quick succession this
gets to the point where Samir is even
ready to make a joke about his own
girlfriend but at the last second he
switches to mocking himself and his
desire to become a comedian the audience
loves this and in the end Samir ends up
yelling his own name and erasing himself
in the process this course is all of the
people who've previously been 4 raised
to come back the episode closes with
Samir's friend and competing comedian
and countering JC wheeler at the bar and
asking him for some career advice so
what does this all mean well to me that
episode is about a quest for fame and
how in striving for it we are set to
lose those around us as the two don't
really tend to go well together Samir
was pretty ruthless and ambitious in his
quest for recognition and because of
this he was willing to sacrifice those
around him until he eventually realized
that he had become a monster and that
the world would be better off without
him however the ending shows that there
will always be those willing to step up
and attempt to make their own mark no
matter at the cost and Samir ultimately
becomes a victim of his own success
doomed to fall by the wayside before he
was ever able to make it due to the
bridges he burned a long way overall I
thought the episode was ok but I don't
really think that the series should have
led with this this story in comparison
to Twilight Zone episodes from the past
was pretty weak and it didn't really
inspire me all that much I really hope
the rest of the season is better than
this one because it was quite middling
and a bit of a disappointment after all
the height obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this episode and if
there's anything I missed make sure you
leave it in the comments
let me know if you're excited for the
rest of the series and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of the
finale of The Walking Dead which would
be linked at the end this is a channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]